google cloud partnered with vmware
because we're in the business of helping
simplify the cloud journey for customers
customers want to move to the cloud for
scale agility
lowering their cost and developing a
whole new set of cloud native services
and apps
it eliminates the need for them to
manage infrastructure
and lets them focus on building new
solutions
for their customers
[Music]
i love that video tells you in 30
seconds what this whole session is about
hi everyone i'm manoj sharma and i lead
the vmware product management team in
google cloud
and i'm really happy to be here and
let's get going
today in the session we learn the
problems that enterprises face when they
look to transform to the cloud
we'll see how google is addressing this
problem
through our new offering called vmware
engine
we'll also get a look at the scenarios
where the service helps
to solve these problems and then we'll
take a deeper look into
how various google cloud services can
improve the way you consume vmware
so by now we all understand the benefits
of the cloud
including the innovation and the agility
it can bring
and we've understood this for years now
but when we look at the report card of
cloud transformation
we find that most applications are still
on premises
and so we're wondering why is that we
spoke to hundreds of customers to find
out
why and we heard that companies
often find cloud transformation projects
to be more expensive
time consuming and disruptive to
operations
than what they originally thought
so we sat down with them to understand
why that is the case
and we learned that it's not that
obvious
if you're writing a new application then
the cloud has a great
set of tools and solutions to help you
build it
but what if it's an existing app
oftentimes the app is written by someone
else or
it's a third party app and keep in mind
it's not just about
running the application or the vm
it does a lot more with the application
than just let it run
it creates business continuity through
backup and dr
it creates operations support through
monitoring and logging
and it has to meet audit and compliance
requirements
so to summarize we realize that the key
reason
cloud adoption is slow is that it needs
to solve the problem holistically
and not just get a platform to run
applications
and when we look inside it the largest
on-premises it platform is vmware
used by over 500 000 users
and it runs over 55 million virtual
machines worldwide
and google and vmware recognized as you
saw earlier in the video
that they can not only help their
customers transform to the cloud but
also
accelerate and simplify the
transformation by partnering
and so we announced our partnership late
last year to make
vmware a first-class citizen of google
cloud
and that's the theme you will see
throughout this presentation
it's a theme of partnership a theme of
complementarity
and how one makes the other better
we'll see how you can get the best
vmware experience on the planet
on google cloud and what better way to
describe what we're doing than to see a
demo
and now we're going to put on the hat of
an ip administrator
looking to run vmware on google cloud
because let's say for example you have
run out of capacity on premises so
let's take a look so you've come to the
google cloud console
to run vmware you can get access to the
console by clicking on vmware engine
which allows you to not only create a
vmware environment but also perform
common setup and management functions
so let's go ahead and create a vmware
private cloud
a private cloud is a dedicated private
capacity
running on google bare metals and on
google cloud locations operated by
google
you get hyper conversion nodes that give
you high levels of vm density you can
choose how many nodes you want in your
initial environment
you can always change this later as we
shall see you allocate a network space
for this environment and that's
it four simple clicks and you can go
ahead and create
a new vmware environment in the cloud
what you'll find is
that the service gives you the fastest
vmware experience from the time you
click to the time you consume the vmware
it just takes 30 to 40 minutes the
environment is very compatible with how
you consume vmware on-prem
as well it runs a fully redundant 100
gigs of networking
giving you four lines of availability in
a single site
and uh you can consume vmware in a very
cloud-like
fashion so let's say i miscalculated
my initial capacity well not a problem i
can go ahead and expand my environment
by adding nodes and this takes a matter
of minutes
uh in the cloud compared to much longer
doing the same thing on premises
now the service includes all
networking necessary to run vmware
uh it has a bunch of service features to
enable vmware networking including
uh subnet views that allows you to see
all your management and workload
networks you can always
create firewalls to segment and secure
your environment
so here in this interface i'm creating a
firewall rule
the interface is very simple and
flexible to capture
all the common options you can also
once you've done this security procedure
allocate public ips and the public ip
allocation might be to a desktop or a
web server
and it's an action that takes that
that's instant
you know and this kind of activity would
normally take much longer on premises
you can also create site-to-site vpn
devices to get out of band management
support
now my vmware environment is
fully integrated with google cloud
networking so that i can connect to
on-premises
to other vms in google cloud services
directly
and natively over the cloud fabric
i can even control policies such as
disallowing network egress from the
cloud and
vmware cloud environment and so
it's a very flexible and complete
network interface
now the service also comes with a lot of
enterprise manageability features
i can see alerts for any important
changes happening in the environment
i can see all activity being performed
by
various users in the system and i can
get a
log of all such actions and i can see a
bird's eye view of the account
as well as other users in the system
now let's do the most common action
expected in the environment
which is to access the vmware interface
to do that i just go to a private cloud
and i
can access the vsphere ui
from that cloud which is my
familiar and common vmware interface i
can now use that interface to deploy
workloads and configure policies or
migrate workloads from
on-premises onto this environment now
the platform is fully integrated with
google cloud as i mentioned
not only do i use my google cloud
identities to do what i just did
but i can also
configure my environment to live inside
vpc subnets
and i can therefore
essentially get a view of my networking
across
my public cloud other public cloud
services and vmware
and i can also see my consumption and
billing in one place in the console
alongside all the other consumption that
i'm doing in this context
and what's more i also get end-to-end
support for
this service from google
and whether it's a vmware problem or a
google cloud problem
the service will address that for you
so now let's go ahead and put this in
context
when you think about cloud
transformation you need to think about
the amount of
change you're making to your deployment
are you changing or creating an app
with modern application design or are
you also changing
it processes around that and and
creating
new ones if you're changing both
the it and the app architectures
or if you're developing green field apps
you can go directly to the cloud native
designs
using kubernetes or the various other
application
platform services that exist in google
cloud
but if you're keeping the app as is
inside the vm
you can deploy the vm directly into the
cloud
this implies of course you're changing
it and set up new procedures
for let's say backup or monitoring
however if you don't have the luxury of
changing either
then you can go directly into
the vmware deployment as i just showed
you from your on-premise vmware
using vmware engine so let's summarize
what you get when you consume this
service
you get dedicated isolated
infrastructure
running on physical bare metal nodes
it also includes all networking required
includes the private distributed storage
that's necessary to consume vmware
you get high levels of ram as well as
storage to meet your application
resource needs
on the latest gear of all flash nvme
devices for storage
you get 100 gigabits of
non-oversubscribed fully redundant
network designs
and in the vmware stack the service
takes care of all lifecycle management
including upgrades and failure handling
and the service as i mentioned is fully
integrated from a networking standpoint
from a billing standpoint from an
identity standpoint
as well as an end-to-end support
standpoint
so what are the benefits of all these
features and capabilities
now in talking with customers two
factors
stood out as key impediments in
performing
cloud transformation and cloud
migrations
the first is of course that there's a
lot of overhead in migration if you'd
want to change the app or you changed
the it as we saw
the other is the implications the cost
implications of doing these kinds of
changes
the retraining that you need
and all of this results in you know a
substantial slowdown and a substantial
risk to your business in some in
in many cases and as you can see
vmware engine solves these problems
the ease of migration there's no change
to your vm or your app required
you can migrate those applications
directly and maintain your continuity
there's no retooling required you use
the exact same tools for business
continuity and operations and security
and networking as you
as you do on premises but the service
helps you substantially lower your costs
since the environment is a dedicated
cloud you do not have to allocate
cpu resources 100 to your vms
all workloads do not burst together and
the workloads are all pooled into an
environment that's dedicated to you so
you can use the vmware
platform's over commit capabilities to
improve the workload density
and this lowers cost plus the fact that
you can
match your demand and your capacity by
allocating
capacity only as much as you need rather
than provisioning it for peak
that also helps you keep the cost low
and with the google cloud efficiencies
and economies of scale
you can expect the benefits to be passed
on to you
through lower costs in the service
not to mention of course the google
cloud security
the self-service and automated
consumption that also improves your
efficiency and agility and the various
innovative services that we learn more
about subsequently in this presentation
and so all these benefits keep adding up
to the initial benefits of migration and
easy cloud transformation
so when should you think about this
service
the first and foremost kind of scenario
that we see
is a capacity event
such as a data center uh reaching
the the end of the lease or a hardware
farm that needs a refresh
so that's a scenario where you would
need more capacity and that's a good
reason to think about
running vmware in google cloud
when you'd like to set up a new dr
environment that's another
good example rather than go out and get
another data center stood up and pay the
extra cost
or for example if you have multiple dr
environments
you want to consolidate them and reduce
costs once again
that's a good reason to consider br to
vmware engine from your on-premise or
your lease data center vmware
now due to the private dedicated nature
and with the high-end infrastructure
the nvme the 100 gigs of networking we
talked about
you can get really high levels of
performance for
your performance sensitive and latency
sensitive workloads these could be
transactional workloads operational
workloads
real-time analytics high-performance
computing and so forth
now the vmware stack has advanced and
powerful vdi
infrastructure and in today's
work from home contexts you can very
easily
expand to take advantage of the cloud
capacity and agility
for your desktop needs and remote worker
needs
now the service is not just about
getting vmware in the cloud and stopping
there
you want to take advantage of cloud
services
of new application architectures of the
innovation
of google cloud services you can develop
new apps in gke and anthos for example
which can reach back into the databases
that are running on vmware or you can
use services such as bigquery to
transform your data
or data warehousing or supercharge your
analytics
through ai and ml services that google
cloud
offers and we'll see some examples
now our service has been in preview with
many customer over the last
customers over the last few months
deutsche bohr's group
is a marketplace organizer for the
trading of shares and other securities
and is a transaction services provider
in the financial markets
they found that the instant provisioning
the ability to get a new vmware
environment in a few minutes
is very compelling as it brings a new
level of agility to their i.t
qad incorporated is a software company
that provides enterprise resource
planning software
and related a software for manufacturing
companies
they found that the automated deploy the
upgrade
the failure handling and the easy dr
frees them from infrastructure
dependencies
and helps them focus on the consumption
and the workload delivery
so one of the questions i very often get
is
can i just bring vmware or can i bring
everything else that i do on top of that
how can i make my vmware consumption
better in the cloud
the answer is we offer a fully
compatible vmware experience
so you can bring your existing tools and
processes
as is you can bring vmware first party
tools
for operations management for dr
for large-scale infrastructure
management through vrealize automation
and bcloud director you can also take
advantage of the vmware ecosystem
of a providers technology providers
in the spaces of backup business
continuity dr
monitoring security
networking and so forth in addition you
can take advantage of google cloud
services
which can improve the way you monitor
vmware
as well as the rest of your applications
the way you backup the way you do
application development the way you can
do
warehousing and i'm going to give very
concrete and specific examples of all of
these in subsequent slides
in addition third parties are building
support for google cloud
uh netapp is an uh partner that offers
native support for their storage
platform
uh which is integrated with google cloud
and
and it enables use cases such as br
data movement and also workload storage
so i've talked about some examples now
let's double click
into how google cloud can actually
supercharge vmware consumption
by looking at some examples of service
integrations
so once you have your vmware environment
up and running in google cloud
a key question is how do you enable data
protection for
production workloads backup
is the most common way to achieve that
the good news is that since the service
offers a native vmware platform
it is fully compatible with your
existing vmware based
backup tools so you can get into
production quickly with
no change however in the cloud you can
do better
in your on-premise deployments you often
have secondary storage
which are lower cost storage
environments to store backups
however to ensure that you can survive
local site failures you often have to do
off-site backups
into tape drives through tape drives or
perhaps into the cloud
but now that your vmware is literally in
the cloud
there is no need to make expensive
copies and to ship data to multiple
locations to get better
availability and disaster resiliency
you can back up your data into cloud
storage and choose how quickly you want
to restore
your data as well as the redundancy
level
of your storage backups
so for example you can choose to have
your data stored in near line storage
and select geo redundancy to ensure that
you can survive
a single site failure at an extremely
low price point
thus you can get better recovery times
better availability
and at much lower cost compared to your
on-premise
backup infrastructure
now your vmware infrastructure has
production workloads
databases and line of business
applications
as you look to modernize this
infrastructure you want to take
advantage of technologies like
containers and kubernetes well
anthos lets you build and manage
container-based hybrid and multi-cloud
applications
you develop once and run these
applications
across your existing on-premises
infrastructure
or any major public cloud provider
using anthos you can run these
applications on vmware engine
as well some of these benefits
some of the benefits of doing this is
that you get a dedicated
private environment with latest hardware
100 gigs of networking your workloads
can be right
next to the databases for the lowest
latency and best performance
and since your environment is single
tenant you get the benefits of the
privacy and the security of dedicated
infra
now as you consume vmware in the cloud
you also want to ensure
that you avoid the screen swivel for
operations management
for example if you have a performance
problem you want to troubleshoot
all aspects of the application
dependencies in one place
rather than go to different systems to
solve different parts of the problem
while the vmware engine fully supports
existing vmware monitoring and logging
tools without changes
as you start to develop hybrid
applications for example using anthos
that partially might live outside of
vmware
getting all of your operations data in
one place is going to be important
to solve this problem you can use google
cloud's operations
formerly it was known as stackdriver
to collect metrics logs traces
across vmware engine as well as other
google cloud services
you can then use the built-in out of the
box dashboards to view and monitor the
platform and the applications
and you can then query and analyze these
signals intelligently
and you can see information from the
platform
from vcenter from esxi and you can do
log analysis
there's no agent required and in fact vm
level data
cpu memory disk and network usage
are all included all available as part
of the signals that come from the vmware
platform without having to install any
agents inside the workloads themselves
the vms themselves
but if you so want you want deeper view
into the application metrics
telemetry then you can use open source
agents
and collect additional logs and metrics
from inside the vm
and from the application context
directly
so if you want to troubleshoot any
application or gain insights for
optimization or usage
you can do it all in one place in
google cloud's operations
now when you peek inside a typical
vmware deployment
you're going to find that the top
workloads are often based on databases
like
sql server and oracle
and typically these are operational
transactional databases
that feed into data warehousing
infrastructures
often these warehousing infrastructures
are proprietary
and expensive they require explicit
infrastructure management and
maintenance
but google provides data services that
simplifies
and supercharges these this process
bigquery is a serverless highly scalable
and cost effective data warehouse
designed to help you turn
big data into informed business
decisions
it works seamlessly for real-time
analytics
and automatically scales
as your data scales so that your data
continues to make sense to you without
you having to
change your infrastructure every time
you have a scale change
tools like tableau and data studio work
seamlessly with bigquery to help you
better understand your information
and you can use services such as cloud
data flow
to incrementally ingest data embellish
it
with different sources coming from
various different systems
clean it dynamically before it's fed
into the big query system
so you can become more efficient
more intelligent and more agile with
data analytic with data analysis
and save cost while you are at it
so as you can see the service enables
you to not only bring
vmware to google cloud but
also the services and innovation of
google cloud to vmware to give you the
best of both worlds
so now that you've seen all the features
and benefits of running vmware in google
cloud
when and where can you get it
as you see the deployment plan in this
screen
google cloud is fully committed to make
sure that
you get vmware in the location you
prefer
we are expanding quickly and widely
and you should be able to consume vmware
in 10 regions by the end of this year
and i have to note that this is the
fastest
and widest deployment of a vmware
in the public cloud from any provider
so to summarize you can see that google
has a number of
technical advantage that gives you a
very compelling
very compatible and high performance
enterprise infrastructure
for your vmware environments
the vmware service that vmware engine
offers
is fully integrated with google cloud
it gives you the highest level of
availability of
any cloud provider and you get a single
source
for all your vmware and cloud needs
including support transaction billing
and so forth so it's a very cost
effective
and very compelling offer
that helps you supercharge your cloud
transformation
and application modernization
so that's a wrap folks if you would like
to find out more
you can go to the product page at
cloud.google.com
vmware engine if you have any questions
for the product team you can send an
email to vmware
engine google.com and you can also
check out other sessions chat with
vmware engine experts
and also check out a digital demo via
the next
on air page with that
i thank you for your time and attention
today
and i hope you all stay safe
thank you